We often hear about genes only when
something goes wrong - when mutations,
mistakes made in the DNA sequence, cause
a disease like cancer or cystic fibrosis.
But what happens inside our cells that leads
from a mutation in DNA to the physical symptoms
of a disease? Why do some mutations cause
positive outcomes, or no change at all?
To answer these questions, we take a closer look
at how information flows from genes, to RNA,
to proteins, to all the physical structures
and processes that make up living things.
You might ask yourself what are the
relationships between genes and proteins,
this is such an important concept for biologists
that we've dabbed it the Central Dogma.
The Central Dogma essentially
explains how biology works.
The Central Dogma explains how the instruction
in DNA are converted into proteins and the way
this is done. First, the RNA polymerase reads the
code in the DNA and turns it into messenger RNA.
mRNA is very similar in structure to DNA except
that it is single stranded. The mRNA then leaves
the nucleus and goes out to the cytoplasm of the
cell. There it finds another set of proteins and
it's a large protein complex made up of about 70
different proteins plus additional RNA molecules.
This complex molecule is called the ribosome. The
ribosome decodes the message that's on the mRNA
and converts it into a protein. So, the
Central Dogma explains this whole process from
the stored code to a message to a protein,
and the proteins are who do all the work.